so it's uh it's kind of funny when we
had Jeremy boring on the show earlier
this week it was around the same time
Disney announced that they were losing
money due to their politics and I'm like
wow what a what what a perfect timing
and so today we're hearing this big news
that the GOP is calling for a travel
band with China over something called
the white lung which is reportedly
popping up in the US Europe and China in
China there's videos of more lockdowns
of uh what look like pandemic lockdown
measures and it feels kind of like this
is how it gets started and the funny
thing is we are hanging out with some of
our friends who have some experience
with with lockdowns and uh so we're
really excited uh before we get into
everything we we we do have some other
news I don't know how much we're we're
going to get into uh I guess we'll just
we we'll leave it there for now but go
to Cas brew.com if you want to support
the show we have the best cup of coffee
you you'll ever have we've got uh uh
appalachin kns of course rise with the
brto Jr and if you support our work with
these shows and if you want to see our
coffee shop expand and take off once we
do then definitely go to casper.com but
also don't forget to go to
timcast.net defiant uh friends of ours
we're really excited so smash that like
button subscribe do all that stuff share
the show with your friends let's uh
start whoever whoever wants to take the
lead and introduce your introduce
yourselves I'd like to start by saying
I'm not going to get the white lung
vaccine I don't care I don't well all
right at at no cost I don't know what
you can say on the show or not but I I'm
already refusing it beforehand well okay
uh hey how are you Tim I'm Ticky Barrett
from the defiant and I'm here with uh
Pete parda from the defiant and behind
me if you can get a shot of them and the
other members of the defiant are here
and thanks for having us and I I I I I
hear that you have names you forgot our
name forget the names dude not the guys
in the back the guys on the stools I
don't know there's that there's the
young guy there's the guy that always
wears the hat and then there's the guy
from Smashmouth they all oh yeah guy
from smashou that's how I refer to him
well all right no no no that's Joey
laka right there
that's Johnny Rio Johnny Rio was in the
street dogs Joey Lorac was from the
Briggs and that's right there is Greg
Camp who's super super talented
songwriter has written songs for just
about everybody he's he's tremendous and
very very talented songwriter he wrote
everybody's favorite Smash Mouth songs
is that true yes I heard he wrote the
only ones you've probably heard walking
on the Sun the best ones and Allstar he
wrote that and then a bunch of other on
Allstar is like one of the greatest
songs ever written
wow High Praise but because not only was
it a good pop song everybody liked but
it became a meme starting that's the
first thing we disagree on I still know
all the words but it's it's not so much
about me saying I like the song I'm
saying like that song was ubiquitous
when it came out and then it became a
meme everybody just kept playing it on
the inter like crazy like it was fun it
was funny did you write it from start to
finish yes I did in a in a garage O How
long did it take you to write it uh a
few days probably yeah it was the lot
the last song to be added to that album
they basically told us to go back to the
drawing board the album wasn't finished
and I wrote that one and another one and
those were the first two singles there
you go well Pete of course uh uh you've
been on this show before right or I've
not done RL did culture with you yeah so
and uh so you are the drummer uh for a
lot of bands a lot of bands yeah
currently the defiant and a little group
called Tim cast as well yeah I don't
know I we just call it that I guess but
he Pete has done the drums for our Music
which is awesome you were in The
Offspring for a very long time Offspring
for a very long time face to face saves
the day I've done tours with My Chemical
Romance and dvo and um you know lost my
gig over not being able to get the Cod
vaccine and refused to take a fake card
and so some people might know me from
all of that drama and you obviously I
wasn't the only one in the industry that
was getting leaned on it happened
everywhere and um so yeah um we have our
new band The defiant together and we're
excited to be here tonight play some
music right on and and we got some news
talk about too we got cter Banks hanging
out cuz he's our in-house music guy
what's up guys it's a pleasure to be
here with the defiant Pete as always I
know every Smashmouth song so it's great
to be here with you as well Greg and uh
yeah let's got Ian CR Carter have you
heard of the Boss Tones I have so just
asking I talking about old bands they
were formidable the Boss Tones you guys
kind of helped guide me as thank you a
teenager will you shut off Carter's
mic um well I got a question for you
Dicky how come you you called the band
The Mighty Mighty Boss Tones and not
just the Mighty Boss Tones or the Boss
Tones that's a fantastic question Ian
and all right let's settle in because
this is quite an answer um there was
another band we found out later on and
this is long before you could Google or
you know check out like we did with the
defiant where we were checking out if
there's other bands and we went through
a long long list of different names we
were going to have and we finally settle
on the defiant but with the Boss Tones
somebody told us like we were just about
to put out the record and someone said
you know there's there's a band from the
' 50s they were a Harvard like Acappella
sort of dwop band called uh the bossones
and we're like we don't want to
change the name of the band this late in
the game so then there was this
bartender who was always calling us the
mighty mighty bossones he was like the
mighty mighty bossones which we were far
from mighty or even mighty mighty we Far
From Any Mighty at all but we quickly
slapped that on the album cover and said
all right will be the mighty mighty
bossones and uh I I we never looked back
I I mean Rascal King when you're like
man could he ever talk dude that line
and that song If you guys don't know the
Rascal King you got to put it on in the
background during this interview for a
little while but that that that just
shook me to the core man like I was an
actor at the time so it was nice to hear
a guy talking about the value of being a
smooth talker and even though the the
Rascal King probably wasn't dude don't
tell me I know talk to your boy by the
way the Bost are great hey man right on
all right we got Smashmouth over there
we got
sege yo yeah I'm hanging out I'm excited
for the show tonight guys with the best
hair on Earth by the way what's going on
thanks bro we H with you all day your
hair got great that's like the 80s girl
thing though where you get the
bangs going on if you turn sideways it's
just a wave but from the front looks big
so it is how it goes peacock anyways
well let's jump into this first story
which will kick off everything we have
this uh breaking today GOP Senators
called for China travel ban to prevent
mystery illness spread the Senators
wrote to President Biden demanding he
immediately restrict travel between the
US and China okay I mean that's that's
the story right you get Marco Ruby you
get J Vance you get Rick Scott you get
Tommy tuberville Mike Brawn you get all
these GOP Senators this is around the
same time it was like it was end of
December into January we started hearing
about this mystery illness back in 2019
to 20120 a lot of people have been
predicting that there was going to be
some kind of lockdown measure okay and
where was that Tak place at that time
the the first one yeah
China
coincidence well here we go man so now
take a look at this what is causing the
white lung oh this is okay remember when
these photos came out of people's lungs
and they were white and now it's like
happening all over again it's kind of
it's kind of wild because you know
basically you I I don't think all of you
in the band but some many of you I think
have stories of defying the lockdowns
the restrictions the mandates mhm and so
the day you're like Hey we're going to
come on and we're going to talk about
this we get this story about it's it's
all starting again and now of course
they are saying no no don't worry
there's not going to be another pandemic
Health back were saying don't worry
about it but that's the other thing they
did when covid first started you had
foui saying that you didn't have to wear
masks don't worry it's not that big a
deal YouTube was actually restricting
content that was talking about it and
then all of a sudden it turned into the
whole country locking down restrictions
on businesses mandates for for certain
Medical Treatments oh remember I'm
hoping that we don't go there but hey
welcome to the show guys what a day to
join us well I couldn't believe it you
you had that up earlier on the screen I
said to you I'm like that's not from
today yeah it's like that happened today
dude yeah so and then we pulled up the
band white long which it was right yeah
Google searched white long there like
apparently there's a band called white
long already they've been around for for
several several years I mean this is
their time to shine baby search
algorithm you know what I'm not going to
live in fear I'm done with it I think a
big part of what happened with Co was
people were afraid and that's were you
afraid last time I part of me was like
What if this turns into I'm not even
letting my mind go there this time like
I'm right wash your hands stay healthy
be your best self that that it I was
afraid for about 15 seconds and then I I
smelled early on yeah man it's
I mean letting letting letting like a a
scientific technocracy guide the world
is like I'm not you got a stinky BR on
your mic hey stink bug oh what's
happening dude what's he doing here you
got you gotta carries lung
dude be careful well hold on those stink
bugs are from China yeah for real
they're a
marmorated an invasive species in the 9s
talk about was that intentional did they
well they apparently they arrived in uh
1996 and Pa I did all this research was
like where do these come from and how do
I get rid of them and those Lantern
flies I AR those from China too probably
I don't know they're spreading all over
and they're big and they're nasty and
they we have these weird jelly you
you're not kidding me that bug is from
China yeah from there's also that an
invasive species in China there's like a
wasp that kills and eats it but out here
there's nothing so it's spreading like
wildfire it's all over buildings that
one disease Tik Tock have you heard of
it that's from
China that's spreading mind viruses
mainly infects phones well let's let's
let's jump back in time can China send
that wasp over I think there's something
about The Temper the temperature they
don't do well and what can we get our
wasp take care of it but let's let's
let's do this like basically we have
this story and I don't know if this goes
anywhere this is it the Myster
mysterious illness they're saying oh no
who knows and I'm you know I think the
price of freedom is eternal vigilance so
we should pay attention to these stories
and uh I don't know what to tell you man
you got to you got to figure out what's
right for you you gotta you gotta you
got to talk to a medical practitioner
that you trust when these things get get
wild but I do think when it comes to
government authoritarianism it's
entirely another question we should just
say no and I hope everybody learned
their lesson from the from the get-go
but let's go back in time and talk about
why you guys are defiant and you know
what is that all about I refuse to wipe
down my grow groceries this time I don't
care what they say I'm not going to is
that why they fired you the first time
you like brought in groceries to the
studio and like I Ain wiping
them well the first time I was no I just
I didn't want to get the covid shot and
I wasn't afraid of the co shot and
everything I just didn't I didn't like
the message I didn't like the you know
what it was sending I didn't you know
could did I think I was going to die
from it no but I I didn't I didn't want
to get it so um
and the the company I worked for was
Disney and they own the TV show so you
Kimmel yes I was Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy
Kimmel's announcer for 20 years on Jimmy
Kimmel Live wow and um Jimmy wasn't
happy that I wasn't going to get that
vaccine and all the producers of the
show were very upset with
me but by that time I was living I had
left California and I was living in
Arizona cuz my kid I brought my kids
there cuz
uh they uh wanted kids to play with and
Pasadena California was very you know
very tight and very restricted and so we
went there and they had cousins that
lived there so um then Jimmy found out
that I wasn't going to get the shot and
he was like what the hell are you doing
and then to his you know in all fairness
to him he you know tried to keep me for
as long as he could and then this you
know piece of paper came in from the
Disney and said all Disney employees
have to get the vaccine and then you
know got and I was in I was actually
announcing the show from my garage in
Arizona of a house that I was would they
like send you a script like in the day
and then you'd read it I would go into
my garage and put on a pair of
headphones like this and fire up a
computer and I was right in the control
room and they were you know so it was
like 54 oh so like you were live on the
show yeah oh wow oh that's crazy but
they were like even though you're in
your own home n you can't you're fired
no and then all of a sudden it kind of
became important for me to come back to
California they need we need you in the
studio which wow really you know maybe
they did I you know what whatever it's
their
show but um so you know but once that
came in then it was nothing anybody
could do to keep me on the show and so
Jimmy tried he did I mean I mean yeah I
believe he did I'm not a fan of that guy
that's what was so it's it's a bummer is
it what was so it's um you know like
like me and Adam were really close
friends with Jimmy because 20 years it's
hard you know like so many friends and
friendships were busting up and breaking
up and I I was a victim of that and
there's people in my life that I don't
really care about so much anymore that I
once cared greatly about and said H you
know you've shown your colors you show
show show show me who you are but um
it's hard you know it's they're close
friendships I I I have to wonder if
they're if if if you're not friends now
were you ever really friends that's what
we say you know like we've had people
who come on this show we have people who
work here and they get texts from people
insulting them and saying I can't be
friends with you and they're like oh
that's crazy and I'm like that person
was never your friend like what did you
do by saying things you've always said
and it's just if these people are more
concern concerned about fitting in with
strangers yeah than being than caring
for someone they've known for decades
they never friend in the first place
well I I agree with you 100% but then in
this instance that never happened you
know so do you know do I have friends
that and this is lifelong and I'm older
than you Tim I've had friends you know
that politically or ideologically we
don't think the same way but before all
this covid crap and before everything
that went down that was okay you know
someone told me you know they were
voting for George Bush and I and you
know I was Voting a different way I was
like okay but I I can still be your
friend you know that's all changed I
think Trump changed everything I don't I
think Trump's a symptom I don't think
Trump personally changed it I think no I
think the Trump era yeah the Trump era
is people can't cannot deal with if you
know I'm I'm kind of you know part of me
is glad it all went down because you
really get to see who's evil it's yeah
kind of sorts you know the rotten fruit
sort of exposed itself and it's
important not to hate though because
it's like this dumbass s up man it's
like hate the left and the right and the
this and the them and the the up and the
down and like the and it's like it's all
getting social media and they're like
did you see far left this guy's skin
color is this color and this one's this
color and it's like who gives like who
cares yeah but look amen so what I'm
what I'm talking about is I used to be I
I was a huge fan of The Offspring
and then I heard Pete's story and
started talking to Pete and now I am the
opposite of whatever a fan would be I'm
a detractor I don't know an opponent I
like their music their early music it's
it is what it is I'm not going to
pretend like all a sudden I hate the
music right but you know I grew up
listening to this stuff and then I found
out what they had did and I'm like wow
these people are bad and noodles blocked
me I he blocked me too that's not a
surprise and I I just will say it's like
a crazy thing just the first song I ever
learned was the kids aren't all right
and then one day he's blocked me on
Twitter and I'm like wow it's kind of
cool you know like like I learned this
guy's song I've never experienced the
pain of noodles blocking me he still
follows you or something I'll I'll hug
you guys after sounds horrible how did
you get through it we're survivors I I
laughed I I I laughed a hearty laugh and
I was like yo this is crazy like I grew
up playing like I choose and the kids
aren't all right gone away and now he's
this guy's like gone hyper political and
blocked me on Twitter and I never even
talked to the guy I don't even know but
I think it was around the time that we
we started talking with you and working
with you yeah and then all of a sudden
he's like you're gone yeah you can't
associate with me I'm a terrible person
apparently so I think I think uh a lot
of people might know your story but a
lot might not do you want to explain
like what went down with you yeah for
sure um you know I I think for for all
of us here anyone in the music industry
in in 2021 they roll this vaccine out
the whole industry is looking at each
other like all right well how do we get
back on the road how do we get back to
making money cuz we
bombarded people with fear for a year or
more of like stay in your home don't
Gather in groups don't go outside don't
be in public and now it's like Well we'd
sure like to start selling tickets again
what do we do and I think you know Live
Nation and the the other people at the
top of the pyramid were like oh how
about we'll have the idea of of the
fully vaccinated tour right so now we
can say everyone in the bands and crew
are fully vaccinated so it's safe for
you to come out and come to the shows
again we'll turn the money spet back on
everyone get back out there and we'll
act you know know CO's over long as you
go get this shot you're going to be
totally safe and at first I I think it
also trickle down to the audiences too
like the the couple big artists out of
the gate you know for whatever reason
they were like oh we're doing these
shows that are only for the vaccinated
bring your vaccine card you can't get in
without it and I think they've all
figured out pretty quickly that you know
mandating the vaccine on your abandon
crew is good for business mandating on
your audience is terrible for business
like they pissed off half of their crowd
cuz a lot of people did not were not
interested in this or were hanging back
to see how it went didn't want to get
one up front and we pissed that it would
be segregating them out of being able to
go back out to concerts and things
especially since I mean it was pretty
well known if you were paying attention
that it didn't stop transmission I mean
the the FDA even in uh January 21 I have
a screenshot of it that my wife took you
know they said well most vaccines are
you know made to to stop the
transmission this one was not tested for
that we are hopeful that that will be
the result and you're kind of like you
know I sent that to some of my very very
smart friends and their response was
well I I I don't know that's weird that
doesn't make sense but I still think
everyone should get it so fall in line
or else right so I knew it was headed my
direction and you know so by summertime
we we had just put out a new record we
were gearing up to get back on and T
like everybody else and you know I I
thought we had to started a dialogue and
there was you know let's try to figure
out a solution here like I'm I'm not
getting this for you know my own medical
reasons and um you're doctor advised
against it doctor advised against it and
um and didn't didn't matter I got a out
of nowhere I got this phone call from
their manager that was just insane
abusive like
threatening bizarre like you know I'm a
drummer I'm used to kind of getting
treated like crap you're at the bottom
of the food chain of the music industry
right you know who what do you call the
guy that hangs out with musicians a
drummer right right so I'm used to
crappy phone calls this was like an
Annihilation it was crazy I got one for
you what do you call a what do you call
a drummer with no girlfriend homeless
there you go so many good many good ones
hold on hold on I got one what's the
difference between a moose and the
mighty mighty bossones what is it that
moose has the horns in the front and the
in the
back there you go you said something
when you were working on Kimmel Dicky
like and this right along with what
you're saying that like Disney came in
they said everyone has to get this
medicine and everything I know about the
medical industry is you go to a doctor
they give you medicine that's tailored
for you they wouldn't say like your
doctor wouldn't say every this I'm going
to prescribe you a medicine for every
human because every human's different so
like it was just shocking in the one
siiz fits-all thing was part of the you
know what led to me to this is
because you know I have I have children
like what I'm going to take my children
are going to take my you know my elderly
mother's going to take it's all going to
be the same thing my my sister who has
Ms she's going to take the same thing
and and it just that made no sense it's
like how do we know this this guy you
know doesn't eat can't eat gluten his
his joints are better with without
eating gluten this person here you know
is whatever it is allergies the we're
all different that's why we have our own
personal Physicians to assess our own
health you know right this felt like the
first time it was the whole world can
take this thing all at once and we're
all we're all good no problem we know
nothing about it and then so here I mean
Dicky's outright like well this doesn't
sound right to me so I'm I'm out and
then Pete you're like my doctor actually
warned me because of my medical history
and they said we don't care yeah no I I
had my medical assumption didn't matter
the manager didn't care and he made it
very clear in no uncertain terms that i'
had the choice of get the shot or I
would be replaced this is why this is
why I'm saying uh it it shows you who's
evil
right how long were you with The
Offspring 14 14 years at this point 14
years yeah and so I'm like wow that was
a really weird phone call like that you
know that seems unnecessary and I took
it to the band they backed him up didn't
didn't matter and everything
deteriorated really quickly after that
and then you know basically overnight
just ghosted like I found out I was
replaced I checked my Southwest app my
flight to rehearsal had been canceled my
access to the band work calendar was
revoked later the same day and that was
just it it was just like you your family
everybody doesn't matter your race and
it's you know they say like you find out
who your friends are but it's like when
you're in a band and you guys can attest
to this too your family like some years
you spend more time on the road with
these people than you spend with your
own family and you know everything
everyone's your family and but you find
out where you are and where you really
stand the first time you say no to
something and you know that's this was
the first no that I had given and I was
gone this sounds like uh it sounds like
the Soviet Union it sounds like how
Communists behaved uh in Salen and
things like that that you are a
terrifying other and you were not
adhering to uh uh what do they what do
they call those things um uh there's
there's a phrase for it I don't know I
got to listen to more James Lindsay like
uh front lines or something like that or
I don't know some phrase where it's like
there's an a narrative everyone must
follow no matter what don't question it
stay in line don't back off and so when
you are even legitimately through
medical reason no no no there's what is
it no no no no there's a word there's a
word for acceptable narratives like you
must agree with the Ukraine war you must
agree with the lockdowns you must agree
with the vaccinations you must side with
these political issues and if you don't
then you're you're outside it's crazy
that like you were saying before before
covid and I would actually add I think
before the Trump era whatever you want
to call it if you were a of different
political background like you could
still be friends and it's was like oh I
don't know I guess and then we talk now
all of a sudden it's like bro they
didn't even call you they were just like
quick quick delete his make him go away
we don't even want to hear his name
anymore that's like weird cult level
yeah not just me to me it was like my
whole family you know our wives were
really close our kids grew up together
and you know and for me the the reason
that I didn't I didn't say anything at
first like I took a month to kind of
clear my head and like see what would
happen cuz I'm just ghosted so I'm like
well maybe I'll hear something back and
so nobody said anything and then they've
got a tour coming up and they've got
shows they had a show in Nashville where
I live and people are hitting me up for
tickets for all these shows that I know
I'm I won't be at anymore so it was like
all right well what do we do here I
don't want to have this conversation 500
different times so you know drafted up a
statement was pretty nice explaining
just basically here's here's why I won't
be there anymore and say anything bad
about anyone and was just like you know
but also said I I don't think this is
right I don't think anybody should be
forced to get this by their employer by
the government by anyone you know and
and so if anybody else feels left out
and lost here like got your back you
know understood and I just figured
firing squad you know flamethrowers and
that would be that but yeah shout out to
the chat it's Mass line it's uh the
political organizational and Leadership
method developed by Ma zetong and the
Chinese Communist party it refers to
formulating policy based on Theory
implementing it based on people's real
world conditions revising Theory and
policy based on actual practice etc etc
but um people make references to like
the Ukraine war starts you must agree
with it and so you end up with this
weird circumstance where the American
political left as we describe it is
critical of the military-industrial
complex supportive of the military--
industrial complex in favor of
pro-choice because my body my choice my
I choose my medical practice but then
you should be forced to undergo Medical
Treatments completely none of none of
these things align logically they align
politically and it's it it's any there's
no logic to it but that is is what you
must adhere to right when it comes to
the US funding of you know Israel for
instance they're like no this is bad we
shouldn't do it when it comes to us
funding of Ukraine it's like Yay you
know those Russians are bad when it
comes to uh uh medical treatment it's my
body my choice except if it's pertaining
to lockdowns and mandates yeah no logic
it was bizarre zero logic and that's the
thing and and then I had people you know
online coming at me like and people I
knew coming at me going oh well you're
you're this right wi thing now or you're
this or that which I that's not
insulting to me like I'm friends of all
political Stripes but it it was just
bizarre that it's like okay if you won't
do this thing here's the laundry list of
things we're going to call you that we
think are terrible but it didn't make
any sense I'm like I'm standing in the
exact place that I've always been I
voted for Bernie Sanders I'm you know
have people yelling Trump supporter just
cuz I wouldn't take the vaccine I'm like
it's not an insult but it's not accurate
they don't care but I thought we weren't
putting you know labels on people that
they didn't ascribe to you I love that
like so you're not queueing on I'm not
yeah go figure right I figured that was
the guy from The Offspring the whole
time you're not is that but did did any
of of you of the other guys in the band
any of you guys experien similar similar
things like refusing to ad here to
lockdowns or anything like that or is it
just these is that is that why these
guys are sitting here at the table I
mean luckily luckily I live in in Texas
right so it's it would it's not an issue
it never even really came up I just
Dicky and Peter my friends and it was
like uh holy crap what's happening to
them is so crazy and wrong and how can I
be there for my friends kind of thing
man that's crazy that's awesome but
that's nice right yeah but that's normal
but that's for all the people that ran
ran from you there's this other group of
people that ran towards you you know and
and you kind of like my wife said well
you know we we're not going to hide here
how do we how do we find our people how
do we find our tribe and for me it was
mostly like to to to speak out and say
something cuz I know tons of people got
fake cards tons of musicians everybody
went back to work kept their head down
I'm just going to ride this out that's
cool but for me and my kids do you want
me to list those names no we're
good I know a bunch I know a bunch of
them a lot of people probably do but
I'll I'll tell you guys what man Tim
wants me to list them you know I'm 50/50
some people deserve privacy it depends
if they're Hypocrites and they're evil
and they're doing nasty things you call
them out but I you know you talk about
the people rushing towards you pretty
sure my mom I don't know for sure but
I'm pretty sure she cried when she found
out that Pete parata the drummer for The
Offspring was was playing drums with us
cuz when I was a little kid playing
Offspring songs and she's bringing like
guitar lessons or whatever this is the
band these are the CDs I got the tab
books for xn on the Ombre smash all at
once and I'm at home I'm playing it all
and then one day she's like The
Offspring drummer is is playing drums
with you like this is so amazing I'm
like well I don't know man I mean it's
crazy and then for Ian when we mentioned
that you coming Dicky Ian starts listing
off all the albums he used to listen to
Royal o man dude screw these people I've
spent the day with Ian I wish your
mother liked me no I'm just Kidd she
probably does it is interesting how if
you're a kid and you have like a hero
that you look up to and then you live
your truest self publicly that you may
end up working with them like that is
mindblowing but maybe you wouldn't want
to because like you know look I I I my
my mom was when I was little she's like
oh you know Dexter Holland he's getting
his HD and all that stuff like she was
so proud that I was looking up to a band
where the lead singer this rock star was
also getting an education and I did
think that was really great you know Tim
he flies his own plane that's true yeah
you know he's a rocket scientist that's
fantastic and he's a bad person he's a
he's a bad guy because know I I just I I
got I got you know if if there's no
there's no excuse man he broke young Tim
skateboarding young 13-year-old heart
child me is like learning now and and is
smashing guitar in the background what a
great guy Pete is I I yeah I mean I
would push back on anyone being bad
people I think sometimes people make
choices that I would consider bad I
didn't enjoy the choice they made for me
um I don't think they're bad people we
were friends right up until I never
heard from them again you know you
you're a nice guy Pete you're a nice guy
but I got to tell you if here here here
here's how I imagine the circumstance
right they're a big touring band right
they're doing a bunch of shows and these
venues mandate it because the government
mandates it but the venues weren't not
all the venues were the venues weren't
mandating it it would they left well I
guess on the audience so yeah some some
venues were saying you know we worse
than I thought but I know plenty of
bands that had you know someone had a
medical exemption and it was accepted
it's not like they were clamping down
cuz no one wanted to cancel shows for
any reason it was just show us a piece
of paper come play your show whether it
says you got it or you can't get it is
is it public how much they made when
they did shows like what their rates
were I don't want to I don't want to out
anybody's private business stuff but I
don't know if it's like publicly known
or something I don't know I don't even
know myself so I'll just I'll just say
you know it it they're not poor right
and my view is if I had a ban if I had a
show if anyone at timcast and we are
going to do shows we're going to do a
bunch of venue stuff and something like
this happened there's no way in hell I
would cut off communication and and
terminate someone I'd worked with for 14
years my worst case scenario would be
something like I'd go to up and I'd say
we got your back we'll keep you in the
studio as long as we can when when when
we can get you back on on on the shows
you're there we'll keep paying you come
hang out the venue doesn't let you in
screw them we may have to get a touring
drummer but we we got you man we're here
with you on this one I wasn't allowed in
the studio either but that's that's
that's that that's it well that's the
thing
though none what I was trying the
conversation I was trying to have with
them was hey we don't know yet you know
the manager screaming at me well there's
borders you can't cross and there I'm
like well which ones well we don't know
yet I great we don't know yet there's
venues you can't get into which venues
well we don't know yet I'm like well
then why are like it just felt like it
was a little soon to pull the trigger on
get this or get out Y and then they go
on tour and I'm getting text messages
and Instagram messages from all these
other bands and they're like dude we're
on the same festival with your old band
today none of us got the shot nobody
asked us for papers or anything and I'm
like I know that know that but I can't
get yeah there was no there was no venue
that fall of 2021 there was no venue in
the United States that I could not have
played with them there I Che I looked up
everyone believe me until I finally had
to just stop caring for my own sanity
and and uh mental safety and um but you
know once they went to England in
October November yeah I wouldn't have
been allowed to go there and I
understand that but then then then I
tell you like I would I would outright
just be like bro uh if you can't come in
the studio because they won't let you if
they can't let you enter the board my my
my response would not be well you can't
cross the border you can't work with us
my response would be looks like you're
getting a year where we're going to pay
you because we're not letting you come
uh keep an eye out and we'll go through
all the fine details as soon as we can
get you in we get you in if you can come
in this country you're with us if not
hang out at home and uh we'll keep
paying you yeah it was it wasn't about
that it was just you you can't say no to
people that are you know well of course
I was not in a position for so many
people though it's also just Optics they
don't they don't they don't want the
controversy they just want to be able to
say that yeah everyone's everyone's that
man man it's it's such a bummer but I
think we're winning on this front it's
not just about you know co uh Trump was
also there's like a similar thing here
but Co was really like with Trump
there's a lot of people voted for him
but kept their mouth shut with Co it was
just like 10x I'm worried something like
this happens again where it's a mass
line you must adhere no matter what
white lung white lung you know I don't
think it'll be white lung people are you
know people are pointing out like it's
it's affecting kids and that's a problem
for sure but is that the way back in
though because you know Co wasn't
affecting kids and that was that was the
one thing they couldn't convince people
and I think that yeah suspect things to
kind of crumble but this one out of no
mistake about it this time it's
affecting kids but I mean like with with
Trump's campaign a lot of people kept
their mouths shut because they didn't
want to be outed as a trump supporter
but there was no harsh extreme
authoritarianism you're not locked in
your home then they do the lockdowns and
it's the same thing it's the it's the
political line you must adhere to no
matter what and the punishment was 10
times more severe Co was no like how
many well just sorry but like there are
some people who got fired for being
Trump supporters but early on it wasn't
as pronounced there are some musicians
who were accused of being a January 6th
they got fired but like the co stuff is
outright take a medical treatment and in
your instance against the advice of your
own doctor and that's crazy because you
should definitely just not listen to
strangers and listen to your doctor and
the the the level of this is what I mean
if you supported Trump or didn't support
Trump it's kind of like who cares you
know but people were weird about it if
you couldn't get a medical treatment
they destroyed your life yeah the the
next level of this follow the line or
else terrifies me it's it's gogs it's do
it or we're putting you in a in a you're
going to go break rocks I I feel like
the co the co experience was like a a
psychological vaccination on the human
consciousness like it was such intense
fear propaganda and numbers being
flashed on CNN death numbers these
horror horror horror scaring people
insane and then numbers start to come
out that it's like a
99.7% survival rate and you're like what
in the hell did we just do for 2 years
and now people are like immune to this
and not 100% but it's like we're ready
for this kind of stupid fear prop now
like I'm I'm hyper Vigilant against fear
propaganda at the moment and I know a
lot a lot of other people that are that
weren't in 2020 well but even at the
time in in 21 I mean people like me that
got let go other band people from bands
all around that got fired my guys want
on tour they all caught Co anyway I
wasn't there to blame like it it didn't
matter you know it was just about
getting everybody in line like we we
everyone has to do this we're not going
to have any denters in the camp you it
exposed a lot of people a lot of a lot
of bad people yeah and now or you don't
agree with bad people but it exposed a
lot of bad of people who are willing to
engage in dark Deeds there you
go we'll age on that one I'll meet you
there I'm just saying like yeah but I
for me with the the white lung or
whatever the new thing that the fact
that this new the newest round of the
vaccine that the brand new one that
nobody wants there's another rounder
there's a new an updated booster right
so now they're saying what hok and New
York was like well if you got the other
ones it doesn't matter now now you need
this new one cuz nobody wants it I think
it's up to 14% uptake so it's like does
that make the other 86% of Americans
antivaxers now did you oh wow that L did
you see K in in Texas they're suing
fizer uh the Texas AG is uh uh suing
fiser stating that fiser lied about the
efficacy of the vaccines and what they
did yeah so that's that's I mean it's
kind of wild to think a state is not
going after these corporations saying
that they put out lies not what really
pissed me off YouTube to this day is
aligned with with an or with a company
that is currently being I believe
they're being sued I believe that's what
Ken Paxton launched right was it a
lawsuit or investigation I think it's a
lawsuit yeah I think it's a lawsuit
YouTube's policies are to align with the
opinions of
capitalist corporations that are selling
a product instead of board certified
doctors who are going on YouTube and
saying like here's my my acate analysis
no those people are getting banned MH
that's crazy yeah anybody who who said
anything against the narrative was
banned if you I wonder if your doctor
went on YouTube and stated here's what
what I told Pete I wonder if you would
have got banned I would imagine yeah
that it was just the fear was so so
elevated in 2020 like June 2020 people
that legitimate doctors that were
offering counter opinions were getting
banned it's not the case anymore a lot
of these same opinions now are Kosher
well CU cuz a lot of the stuff they said
back then that was called conspiracy
stuff has been widely accepted as fact
now but you know no credit given to the
people who were banned and censored over
it but now we all go oh well yeah
obviously it didn't stop transmission
and obviously you know but it's still
you know then they like to twist The
Twist the wording and like well it it
cut down on hospitalizations well it
made your symptoms less severe and it's
like well that's not what was sold to
everyone so so or stuff they can really
even prove right are these guys that you
want to
name are they you know are they are they
are they so uh well I don't I don't want
to do anything that that anybody doesn't
want to me to do I don't I don't I we
want name see you joke I just like the
thought of people I know going oh
to have the list he likes to have
the list I think we got name but but
it's an issue of you name people who've
done bad things like I'm going to critic
Iz The Offspring I think that was a
total dick move and we know they did it
yeah but I think we got to name people
who've done bad things because the issue
is there's a there there these people
are coming up to a fork in the road yeah
there is a path towards the light and a
path towards the dark and they're
looking around like well if I go to the
dark side I'm going to get some free
stuff as long as nobody finds out yeah
they don't want to do the right thing
because they're scared everyone will
watch them do it they're scared that the
people on the dark side will attack them
and they'll get harmed they know that if
they go to the dark side the people on
the light won't attack them you know
what I mean yeah I I good people I
understand what you're saying but I
think that they there's a good
percentage of those people that think
that they're going to the light and I'm
going to the dark I know for a fact I
made my own choices I made my own
decisions you think that they know
willingly I think that no I think it's
like 8020 I think I think 80% of these
people who are standing with I'm going
to need a pencil now we got to do math
we're doing
math I think uh
802 got some paper one in five people
gen
are like know what I'm doing is wrong
but I hope no one finds out because I
don't want to be the one to get the
negative I think for sure I think
there's there's plenty of that here
here's the thing you know whatever we
want to say what thank you give it to me
Professor carry the one carry the one
s's already taken why did you write your
name on I don't know why you wrote your
name on I think it's because I claimed
that piece of paper when I tore it off
so he's like this is yours now
um here's the thing I think
you know we can talk about the negative
we can talk about you know The Offspring
or whatever they didn't do or however
you feel about them or they shattered
young Tim's skateboarding and listening
to Pretty Fly for a White Guy why don't
you get a job that was your song was one
of them yeah super easy it was like f
what is that what that song like f and
yeah it's O oah it's O exactly right
that was everybody's favorite line to
yell at me online was why don't why
won't you get a
jab was like but yo can we just can we
point out how how conservative let me
just finish my thought and and we can go
back to your favorite B but I I think
the I think the point needs to be made
that it's like through all of that you
know me me and Pete are now friends and
me me and the guys from the Define good
good has come from that so whatever like
I'm so past like you know I I mean I I
want things to be different going
forward whatever this white lung may or
may not be or whatever the next you know
they're going to throw at us in
order for corporations to make a lot of
money I hope that we we've learned
something from this like oh I did that
last time but I'm not going to do this
again this time and I think Pete's point
about this you know the 53rd booster
nobody's getting it I think you know
slowly but surely people are starting to
learn whatever is going on here so so
it's it's like I don't I I don't really
the negativity I don't think I need to
to to bask or even dwell or even live in
that at all it to me it's like noodles
and Dexter to Forever will be noodles
and Dexter me and I and and the you know
Todd who plays guitar now I guess for
The Offspring you know bass he's bass he
was bass player but didn't they move him
to guitar he was guitar all the way
around all the way around he wanted the
base job what do you want from me figure
this out I thought that that was like he
was he was bucking to be the guitar all
right so I got it backwards anyway so
he's the bass player he's been my friend
since we we were you know years for a
long time he was a kid when I first met
him and when I wanted to meet Pete when
I found out that you know what had
happened to him and and I wanted said
hey maybe we should make some music
together Todd gave me uh Pete's phone
number easily willingly and not with any
kind of you know anger or anything
so you know I I'll never forget I you
know actually I'll give you my list Tim
you can put it in the safe somewhere I
won't forget you know the way people
behaved in the way they acted and
there's certain things that happen to me
that is in my head but if they came if
these people came out to me be you know
be hey how you doing we played Festival
couple of weeks ago bunch of bands that
I know you know probably very negative
about us were real real welcoming to us
and we were treated really well at the
festival by the people there I'm I'm I'm
more of a figurative divine retribution
kind of guy yeah and uh I think that we
we don't want bad people okay how about
I'll try and but there are really bad
people we don't want them to keep doing
these things and we don't want them to
do it to more people and so what I would
love I would love if after they they
asked Pete the way they did yeah they
couldn't find another drummer and they
were like bro and and not maybe for even
ideological reasons yeah let's say they
go they say okay you know what this this
Pete guy he we've known him for 14 years
and we don't want to work with him
anymore because he won't take this his
doctor doesn't want him to get this this
this vaccine so we're firing him so then
they call up somebody we need a new
drummer and they all go wait you fired
your drummer over what because a doctor
gave I'm not are you nuts you're going
to fire me in two seconds well the
problem with that is is Tim and I know
you love The Offspring so dearly H is
that I like their songs I won't I won't
deny is that playing the drums for The
Offspring is a real easy job so
replacing Pete was no I'm kidding
I well that that was a thing that I
would he was way better drummer they
need I'm just saying if no drummer
agreed to take your position they'd be
forced to say we're sorry Pete and the
and the bad action is is rectified and
through no pain other than you made a
mistake nobody wants to work with you
for doing this because you did a mean
thing to somebody but instead some other
drummer is like I'll take the money I
don't care there are other methods of
Retribution that can manifests like if
Pete were to leave the band and then
Offspring makes another song that's even
better than anything they've done but
the defiant makes one even better than
that well we've already done that I got
I got to be honest yeah I think like the
songs you were playing earlier I was
like wait that was an original and I was
like I thought you guys were just
jamming and it was actually I assumed it
was like a top 40 yeah it's just ours
you know good I mean with the Smashmouth
guy what do you say I mean you got one
of the greatest songwriters of this or
any generation Greg's the smash very
inspired by the bossones actually I'm
just going to let you guys know that
right now thank you that is kind of the
coolest thing ever though to be honest
like just work getting you guys have
getting to work with other musicians
that you've also liked it's a blast and
and not only that because we you know
have the same beliefs and the same sort
of values and and not in a million years
would if someone came to me and said hey
you know my doctor said you know I can't
take this and everybody else is going to
I not I would I figured just like you
said I would have figured out a way yeah
this guy is my friend and that and that
just the way I've always done things and
the way you know if you want to talk I
don't know about the rest of your shirts
but you got you know Pizza got the
Misfits on and Michael Graves has been
here he's he's a rad dude Michael's aod
played on one of his songs he's a great
dude and you know he he had a a
different kind of you know for lack of a
better term cancellation Journey than me
or or other people and whatever but uh
you know he's rad he's rather and let
again I wouldn't have I probably
wouldn't have I met him through you guys
here so you know it was yeah we we the
first Punk show I ever played the with
my band impact unit hardcore band was
opening up for The Misfits oh wow in
Boston I was 17 years old wow yeah see
that's the for for I I think a lot of
people listening right now especially
people have been commenting like they
bought all the bossone records they were
kids listening to stuff people are
commenting yeah yeah they're chatting
they're writing about but I mean like
that story is like so many people are
inspired and that's like the stuff of
Legends for them it was a thrill it was
actually a pretty big kind of famous
show I think they made their video for
brain eaters in Boston the day before
and uh they had a bunch of Boston hard
punk rockers and the got some of the
guys from the Fus dys um Basse Player
for my band impact Unit K kid named Sam
mcky kid nice old man like me um they
were in this and look it up brain eaters
is the name of the song not you Ian oh
and not not even now you can't stop me
not even now I'm talking to the people
commenting oh yeah so it's a great video
of them just uh I guess they're eating
cow brains oh wow kind of kind of just
to wrap up my my my last Point yeah I
can understand I step on it or on
it I don't think so no you know I
understand what you're saying about we
want to find the positive and move
forward and focus on the good I can't I
cann't I couldn't for a million years I
I you know do I don't like my friends
being treated badly but we're moving on
but then my concern is what if they do
it again what if they do it worse what
if they what if what if what if our
culture becomes dominated by people who
know they can get away with doing bad I
think you want to too late forgive for
sure but don't we want to just you know
resist and and say at the very least but
here's the thing about this particular
band is that you know we there was a lot
of there was a lot of anticipation about
us even just doing our first show and
like what that would be like and a lot
of people were like oh they're going to
get booed off stage and all this kind of
thing it's like us doing good and us
doing our music and just you know doing
well is is very powerful and actually
now that you guys with this new album
are going to you know just shatter the
the Billboard Chart and make millions
and millions of dollars everyone's going
to be sorry you know they're going to
regret it sure from your mouth to God's
ears my friend thank you young Tim
that's the thing with still you know
people yell at me online like why are
you still talking about all this why are
and it's like cuz I don't want people to
forget all I see right now is what
you're saying is oh we need an amnesty
we need a you know we're going to memory
hold this you know we did the best we
could with the information we had and
that that's I'm sorry with no
amnesty we need a nberg it's crazy that
they say that when they also so
simultaneously like wished death on you
you know they like I I want I want you
to die I want you to get no hospital
care if you get sick I didn't Kimmel say
that like the things that they said and
now they want you to move on it's like
without saying hey I'm so sorry that I
said such awful things to you they like
to say we all said things that we regret
and I'm like I don't I still back
everything that I said but you know now
that the narrative has shifted
everybody's like well I don't want to
admit I was wrong so maybe we should all
just I'm Sor I'm sorry dude I got to go
I I got to say I mean if you Dicky went
to the hospital Jimmy Kimble thought you
should die I I'm sorry man I don't like
the guy I
homie believe me that broke my heart
yeah believe me and I'll tell you
something I was still announcing the
night he said it wow and he
knew that I was not going to get
vaccinated so and he knew and we were
friends and we talk on the phone Tim
when I tell you we talking hey you know
the whole the same old stuff we always
talked about how you been I this and
that but so yeah it broke my heart but
there was so much else going on at the
time for me and and you know what what
when I decided not to do what I did when
I decided I wasn't going to get that
covid
shot it affected me monetarily too it
affected you know my livelihood and my
lifestyle it wasn't an easy decision but
the reason
made that decision is because there's
people that followed what I do and you
know Boston's fans you know Ian out
there that were Boston fans said well
Dicky Dicky did this so I guess it's
cool and I I just didn't want to send
that signal I didn't want to tell them
not to I'm really excited to say this
next line because uh before the show
when we were talking about you know the
the the Smashmouth music and I'm I
started thinking about the '90s playlist
that we got going on and of course the
impression that I get I mentioned you
have that line in the song I'm not a
cower I've just never been tested I like
to think that if I was I would pass and
I was like I looked up and I was like
bro you passed well thank you for saying
that it's kind of just such a cool thing
for me I'm like I'm a little kid I of
course I knew the song we're we're in my
car I have 90s playlist '90s was the
last decade my favorite decade sorry
guys is the ' 80s but the '90s music of
course has been a rotation and so my
favorite decade is of the 70s that 70s
stuff was great dude what was your
favorite stuff I mean it's true am gold
I liked all of that you know you know
seals and CFT or America all the you
know the California stuff early
California stuff but anyway that line
man it's like I grew up I remember
hearing that it was it was it was
brilliant it's a brilliant lyric the
whole structure of It the song itself
was just that was just about I mean we
were a SCA band playing SCA music
traveling around in a van and then
eventually a bus and we had the
opportunity for you know there was 12
guys in that van that you know could go
from City to City show up people were
excited you were in their town and
they'd come out and hear you play I was
like wow this is a great life which led
me to think about you know Generations
that went before us it's like I'm so you
know the people that live through
Vietnam or you know your grandparents
the Great Depression and and you know
all kinds of and I'm like my generation
just really hasn't had anything yeah you
know and and you know maybe enter you
know 9911 and then you know this for me
this this you know the pandemic and
everything the lockdown so and me being
forced to say oh oh my God I I'm going
to do something that's going to possibly
you know affect you know my family was
it as was it as hard as you imagined a
challenge would be you know when you
wrote that song it was it dude I was
laying awake at night going oh you know
I should just do it I should just go
against all my values I should go
against all you know my beliefs and and
I can do it I'm not you know so I'm not
afraid of it I'm not you know but I had
a very supportive wife and um my kids
are are wonderful they're probably
younger than guy my age should have but
they can't imagine the world without
them but uh I said no but the one thing
that I kept thinking was I don't want
people to get a vaccine based on my
decision when when I know or even I
didn't even want to get the fake card I
didn't want to signal and I didn't want
to you know so for me it was off the
table and I and I couldn't do it and I
know a lot of people who uh I believe
have fake cards nobody nobody says it
explicitly but you get a wink and you're
like I think I know what they're doing
yeah when some there plenty you want me
to read the list I kind of do I know you
that's the thing though when for me with
the the fake card thing cuz that was
suggested too like well we'll just do
this and I like no I don't want to do
that cuz number same I don't want to
look like like I'm okay with any of this
cuz I'm not and I don't want anyone
thinking oh everyone in the band got it
so I should get it too but but not just
that your position was substantially
worse because you have a doctor saying
like hey you know Pete based on your
history I don't think this is a good fit
for you and then you're like I'm going
to tell everyone I I did anyway and not
only are you then saying I'm okay with
this you're also saying even when my
doctor told me not to I did it anyway
and it's like but also you take that
card and then you lose your voice there
now I can never say anything cuz now you
know there's legal ramifications and so
I'm looking at my kids and going well
what am i showing them here if I'm
hiding from this or I'm I'm not standing
up here what kind of father am I so yeah
we're hey Dad what did you do yeah going
to face the firing squ like a deck chair
and I got a fake card right but show
them that there's no opportunity your
job or or and there's no one that above
you your employer government anybody
that should be able to tell you what to
do with your body and if I can't stand
up here and show them how do I expect
them to hold on TOs elves later in life
so for for me if those are the only two
people that were affected by positively
by my decision then that's that's plenty
for me so what's it been like since I
mean so you guys are in a band you got
songs coming out you're playing shows
obviously right yeah yep just just
started playing shows record came out
right before Halloween we've got a show
coming up yeah we got a show next week
in Anaheim with the Aquabats oh W be
super fun wow that's amazing yeah and
and there's no beef everyone's super
chill and the music the fans are going
to show up and
um yeah do you mean beef amongst us just
no no no I mean like like people aren't
screaming and boycotting your shows like
there other band like I'll text you from
the show is this your first but you've
played the show before right yeah we we
played that Festival in Southern
California as well yeah so we just did
one show a few weeks ago this will be
our second show you see you see some of
these some of these guys from these
bands who are running these fake cards
that they like put their heads down and
just like Scuttle out of the room um no
I ran into the teenage fan club is that
the name of that band no teenage bottle
rocket teenage bottle rocket oh yeah and
and it's a band that the Boston took on
the road um years ago when they were
kind of just starting out teenage Bottle
Rock and and they were good guys and and
we enjoyed being around them and I like
the band but during the pandemic there
was a lot of Halal around them where
they were actually you know I'm like
reading the paper and going what's this
all about the teenage bottle rocket is
playing a show in
Florida and if you're V v inated um it's
you know
$20 and if you're unvaccinated it's
$1,000 I remember that you remember that
this teenage bottle rocket so um I was
like I was so angry I was like why the
hell are they doing that and then they
ended up on
CNN and I could see they look like kind
of deer in the headlights on the show on
the CNN show and they real enthusiastic
like CNN was about it like look at these
guys this is just great so you're going
to do good good for you you know if
you're unvaccinated they're like well
you know uh kind of stammering and
stuttering a little bit and and uh the
segment ended but I've I've been mad at
them since like just well that's it was
illegal what they did well well we I we
we covered they were playing this
Festival yeah and we pulled up in the
parking lot and I got out me and Greg
drove down together and I got out and
they were like getting out of their van
next to us like oh the defiant you
know this we kind of I was walking
around like that anyway around the thing
like I was oh you know hello hello how
are you and then defiant is here and um
about halfway through the day one of the
guys from teenage bottle rocket goes
dude I really want to tell you a story
and explain to me
basically he got railroaded the whole
band got railroaded it's like we wanted
to start playing shows again and then
you know all of a sudden this this
promoter starts announcing it's $1,000
for this you know we were scrambling to
find out what the hell is going on and
why are they doing that and then they
got the news involved and once the news
were involved now they're on CNN now
they're on you know people do and this
is at the time where it's kind of you
know well they didn't know what to do so
CNN made a story I mean should they have
said you know hey under no uncertain
circumstances but they didn't know they
didn't want to be thrown in the you know
they all got shots they were all vaccine
vaccinated guys and so
they were agreeing with the thing but
they didn't agree with the the show and
the terms as it was I'm I'm fairly so I
think in the real world you can't
discriminate on the basis of uh
disabilities and things like that yeah
and so there's an issue for someone
who's who's uh goes to the doctor and
the doctor says you're not a candidate
for the vaccination uh like for instance
if Pete went to that show and they tried
charging you a thousand bucks because
your doctor has prohibited you or or
advised you against there's nothing else
you can do that's like what is it uh the
uh the Ada the Americans with
Disabilities Act you're not allowed to
charge someone more money based on you
know a medical treat medical issue
however I kind of feel like you go to
any judge with that I'm not familiar
with the Ada I'm sorry well it's
basically non-discrimination based on
medical issues and disability whereas
EEOC is like non-discrimination in the
workplace based on certain
characteristics and then you have human
rights law and states that bar that
protect uh um like customers and Things
based on race so the Civil Rights Act
would protect you based on race religion
national origin Etc but uh I'm I'm
fairly certain if you brought suit the
judge would ignore the law and just side
with the cult and be like we are all
Marching In lock step we don't care what
the law is well at that time there was
such a fervor and such a oh this is
great they should pay $1,000 what if
they did though and then you would have
all the people that paid 20 and then the
people that paid a th000 and they be
like well now we're unsafe and they're
still here yeah exactly that everyone
safe I doubt anybody paid a th000 I mean
I kind of wish I did but that was the
ridiculous you would have because wear a
t-shirt that says I paid $1,000 to be
here every yeah unvax and then just be
like who wants to stand next to me you
know what I think nobody would care well
that's how ridiculous everything was at
the time though cuz it's like Okay cool
so you're mandating it on your band and
your crew you're not manding mandating
on the crowd is there some invisible
barrier between the crowd and the band
you're all crawling over each other
you're screaming and singing leaning out
in the audience how does it make any
sense medically
that you know half of the people here
don't have it and half do
like that's a good point that's an well
let's let's let's let's let's even go
beyond this I mean the uh uh who who was
it was it Bad Religion they put out that
alt-right song do you remember this the
kids are alt-right I think the name of
it was bad religion yeah yeah yeah that
song was Pro alt-right and it was the
weirdest thing for me that I don't know
if they're trying to be ironic in and
and praising white nationalism or what
was going on but I bring this one up
because something weird happened in the
Trump ERA with punk rock where Punk
became corporate mainstream Rage Against
the Machine is now known as rage on
behalf of the machine like what's up
with this like have you guys experienced
this wasn't my fault yeah you jump ship
I mean you were like I'm been out of
here I just don't think they realize I
don't think they I don't think I don't
think they realize I think people are
into Legacy protection mode like they're
playing prevent defense here everybody's
so scared cuz everyone's getting called
out for something all over the place
right so all these bands are like
locking down hunkering down keep your
head down don't do anything
controversial don't say anything
controversial like let's just ride this
out like everybody worri about getting
their whole Legacy erased for for doing
one thing wrong voting for Trump but
also that that whole concept of like
being anti-establishment being like you
know the man all those kind of
thing is was sort of easy to say when it
didn't really mean anything you know
what I mean it was just like it you
could just throw that stuff out there
that's so but when it actually is you're
right man it's kind of sad yeah how many
how many how many punk rock the man
bands said govern Me Harder daddy as
soon as it came down to the line that's
how I there's such a vast majority of
people too that were coming from a good
place in the sense that they were just
trying to do what they thought was the
right thing and I think that they're
really victims as well they just don't
understand they don't
you know you know I I I I disagree but I
understand what you're saying but I
disagree because that's what we call the
banality of evil yeah uh the the
commonplace actions of the ignorant
masses believing that what they're doing
was a Just Cause right leads to people
being loaded up into train cars and then
brought off to gas TR they just don't
see it though you know what I mean they
think they're doing the right thing and
their power is much bigger than
themselves that are snowflake doesn't
blame itself for the Avalanche but if we
if we this this is what all just comes
back to I
mean all of these people who marched in
lockstep with authoritarian fascistic
ideologies and forced Medical Treatments
will gladly do it again if they think
the pain is on on their side and not on
our side what what I mean is it's like I
was saying with the two roads if they
look over here and all we say is we will
forgive you and just move on they're
like okay then I have no risk whatsoever
for knifing you in the back and and they
look to where they're standing and the
guy next to him says you make one wrong
move and I'll destroy you and they're
like I'm with you I'm with you because
he knows none of you guys will ever
speak out like you like you'll defend
yourselves you'll move on you'll be
successful those are all good things but
it's like you're saying with the you
know I I understand there's a difficult
line of like are you really going to
read off a list of names of bad people
that's why I'm like some people may have
done bad things but we will try to
forgive as many as we can when when when
it makes the most sense we'll try to
inform them and say hey come to the side
of the the light don't do it again
because here's the risks you face but
some of these people are just I'm sorry
man I know you don't agree but I think
some of these people are evil you got to
live you got to like forgive but not
forget like those people lost their
knife privileges cuz if you really think
that they're going to turn around and
knife you in the back like you take
their knife away that's what you get for
doing that I forgive you but you don't
get to use your knife right now and like
if we could take everybody that got the
last three years so catastrophically
wrong who were in charge can we not let
them be in charge again next time and
it's I think it's not worth being angry
about yeah we we should do that there no
account they'll keep but it's not worth
getting it's like if if you're in a
cycle of abuse if you're abused it's
important for you to be able to forgive
that person so you don't live in hatred
because the hatred is just kills you
it's bad for you it's like holding on to
anger only Burns you you know that
metaphor I think it's like sunzoo even
maybe so I think that's the state of
mind I'm not angry with these people I
won't let myself get there but I don't
trust I I I I have less trust for the
the masses than I did before that's for
sure I I just think we need to establish
counter narratives before ahead of time
like we're talked about white claw
whatever the hell it's
called alien
sub talking white what's next is the
power going to go Fang yeah White Fang
Fang White Zombie white zombie I love
him white white lung it's kind of fun
talking what's the next big SC up if we
can talk about it now and ridicule it by
the time it comes around the bend
everyone's ready for it that's the way
to to beat in the future not like scream
at them when they're already coming at
you I want I want to say this because
when I said this to Dicky before the
show he told me to say it on the show
and then he wrote it down cuz I said if
you want to really make a positive
change buying the Defiance new album is
more effective than donating to a
politician and voting I'm not saying
don't vote I'm not saying don't donate
to politicians those are important too
and I think you should definitely vote
but politics is Downstream from culture
and a successful band that so we we we
talk I talk about ways to prevent this
stuff from from happening again here's a
simple way the defiant ends up becoming
a multiplatinum band and you guys are
the biggest thing ever you
know winning the lottery ticket levels
of odds like are you going to crack a
synth pop billboard H 100 and beat
Taylor Swift I gotta be honest I don't
think so but that level of success sorry
guys have faith man but that level of
success is Trend setting sends a message
to regular people that the path of
success is in standing up for these
values being a good person and not being
on the wrong side of history or whatever
they what they call it if the the the
reason I'm so invested in building
culture like we're doing the skate show
I've been posting a ton of skate Clips
is I want young people to look at the
success and say I can be defiant and
succeed like they did if you guys don't
succeed kids are going to grow up
believing I have to just tow the line
otherwise I'm doomed so while voting is
important the cultural the the cultural
uh uh arts arts and music and and media
that persists instructs more
specifically the defiant
the defiant as a band specifically is
going to save the world you got to buy
their come on let's play a song that's
that's right there yeah but I see what
you're saying though you know politics
is very wishy-washy very transient and
follows Trends where do Trends come
Trends from come from culture so yeah I
agree you can affect politics through
culture where you can't do it the other
way around you go to you go you go to
these Pol look they just expelled uh
Santos right he's so I mean that's big
news we're we're having we're having fun
talking cultural stuff yeah Santos is a
republican they say he's a liar and he
lied about all these things so they vote
to expel him from Congress there's a
video of them taking his plaque Off the
Wall removing him from his office Jamal
Bowman the Democrat committed a crime
going to a fire exit pulling the warning
signs off and pulling the alarm and
running away and they don't do anything
to him because the machine the politics
is controlled so even when Republicans
win and all these people are like we're
going to vote rep repan this time
because Democrats are doing all these
bad things what happens they expel the
Republican because he's a liar but not
the Democrat who's literally committing
crimes in the capital complex that's
that that that's what you get with
politics so you know what we need to
make these things Unthinkable and how do
you do that when people are looking to
the media looking at influence looking
at who the big stars are who are people
looking up to it's going to be the
people who are saying screw that that
was wrong and then that will dictate the
rest of how people are going to act when
all the big celebrities TV shows you
know comedy shows people like Kimmel
take the other side of it people get
scared that they don't want to be the
other they want nobody wants to be
othered they want to be part of the
mainstream so when the mainstream
personalities are saying do as you're
told and take the medication regardless
of what your doctor says and YouTube
allows people to do that which is wild
then people are scared like if I speak
up they'll come after me now what if we
inverted that what if the defiant was
bigger than all these other bands and
they said Noah you should just take your
doctor's advice ignore all these people
the government shouldn't Force you then
people are going to say I'm scared to
mandate you see what I mean yes that's
that that's my point I see what you mean
but I want your listeners to understand
that too yes because then they'll buy
your you know
what's you know you know what he's
asking you to do people well and all and
all rically all reality no uncertain
terms Tim is telling you make the
defiant huge well
the defiant official.com by the way the
the simple uh point is if people like
what genre would you describe your music
as punk I we call it Punk yeah yeah if
you're into that kind of music put on
your playlists che check out the songs
the songs are really great and if you're
not into it um put it on your playlist
too I guess if but no look if you're if
you're not into it but you support
ideologically then be an activist and
put it on your playlist and and listen
to it or even more so buy the album to
make a statement yeah I prefer if you
like the music you buy it and that's
kind of why you're doing it but we just
what I want to see is everyone who a
good person that's that's the second
thing we disagree on I don't care if
they like it or not I still just want
just buy it no I'll take it I'll take it
I'm kidding with you good people should
be successful it shouldn't be that you
guys are all good dudes who are sticking
up for your friends or sticking up for
yourselves or just following your
doctor's advice and you get punished for
it it's it's so let let me tell you guys
a story you guys ever hear of uh the Yes
Men these political activists was they
have like a TV show or something
supposed to say yes I think yes I don't
know if they had a show but they they do
these culture jamming pranks and one of
the things they did was on the
anniversary of the Bowa disaster which
was this big uh chemical spill that
happened I think it was in India uh
killed a lot of people on the
anniversary of it or before the
anniversary they made a fake website
that looked like a Dow Chemical website
which owns Union Carbide the company
involved they made this fake website and
the BBC reached out to to their fake
website and asked them to send a
representative to talk about it their
activists though is a trap dude goes on
the BBC and then declares dowo chemical
will liquidate Union Carbide and use all
of the revenue to pay the families and
the victims of the Union of the of the
of the of the Bal disaster and the BBC
was like what like this is insane this
is
crazy became massive news instantly Dow
Chemical instantly put out a press
release saying this is not our
representative we are not doing this we
take no responsibility the stock
collapsed wow and then after it was
cleared up it rebounded that's not good
news what activists pointed out was when
it became apparent to the public that
dowo chemical was doing the right thing
in paying the victims of the disaster
their stock
collapsed people jumped ship and they
lost money for doing the right thing
turns out they weren't w't doing the
right thing they were doing the wrong
thing and the stock rebounded that's the
sad reality of of our of our culture and
our system so I'd prefer it if the
defiant hit billboard number one double
Platinum overnight for whatever reasons
and then we get to lorded over all the
evil people and say maybe you should be
good people and you'd get support as
well instead it's just so so crummy
sometimes when it looks like all the
nasty people are successful and they're
they're winning and they're making money
and and they're you know headlining
these big shows it's not always like
that but you know
feel Optimist I'm optimistic I feel good
will will overcome I agree I do yeah
know I think ultimately Punk is a genre
I always thought it was like hey yeah
yeah I'm yelling my like that's
like Punk but is it more like you're
just you you're considered a punk yeah
hold on I was just getting started into
all right it start again NE what's the
question it just start I am a punk can
you hear my voice like anyway I'm just
kind of that was a joke but like that
it's it's like Punk is it that you're
considered a punk by the mainstream
establishment doesn't matter how you
sing you might be singing a beautiful
soprano voice but if you're saying
things that disrupt The Establishment
are you then the new Punk or is it just
counterculture and the punk happened to
be counterculture at the time that I
mean that's subjective in so many ways I
mean Bob Dylan could be considered punk
rock you
know I would I'd like to say Punk is to
music what your shirt is to
shirts you got a shot yeah it's classy
fantastic beautiful inspiring but also a
sloppy M laughing like that's not what
that shirt is purchased on Amazon shows
the right amount of chest hair that's
some it's made of a synthetic phrase
here I think it's silk I I don't think I
don't think necessarily Punk has to be
angry though I mean our record's not
angry we're not angry people it's very
melodic like but I think the punk
attitude is that you have something to
say yeah I really I really like that
line in your song where it's like bring
on on The Guillotines it's time it's
time you know you know I I recall that
no it's not there it's not there but
yeah it I mean that to me feels like
music in general has gotten really safe
over the last decade or so to where
nobody's I mean especially now
everyone's afraid to say anything so all
the music is very Bland even the the
punk rock stuff is very bland enough
that we're kind of saying something
we're shaking our fist at the man but
we're not really saying something but
hopefully whatever you're going through
you can take from this and think that
the song is about you it's it's bland
enough to apply to everyone but that you
know that's not taking a swing at
anything right you know so I I think for
a band like us to come out and people's
expectations might be because of my
situation or Dicky's situation or any of
our situation that oh these are just
going to be angry guys you know shaking
their fists at the sky and it's not that
at all and I think that's what's been
exciting is for people to discover the
music and be like oh I my expectations
were wildly off base this is actually
really really accessible really good so
you could have like Punk Rock like you
were saying punk pop you could have
Punk rap there's an attitude for it yeah
I mean it is still a musical style as
well but you know it doesn't necessarily
have to be in that box per se so there's
we have the song that I mentioned
earlier the kids are alterri right by
Bad Religion and the response everybody
basically gave was like this song sounds
like they're in support of white
nationalism and it's really weird that
because they just said it was against it
then the left just agreed with them like
one of the lyrics is if you're alone and
feel down Trot and as's an Elixir for
your ills join the alt-right post light
and darken men order there's um
Everybody Needs Somebody join the party
the kids are altright bad religion is
definitely not alt-right if that helps
we know those guys well I know but like
I don't this this song was not written
as as a hard critique of altright it's
actually just writing what they think
and and how if you're feeling down you
can be be like like them and I I I was
like what I just thought that I don't
know I don't I it it was it like like a
bad attempt at trying to be topical and
being political I don't know they have a
tendency to be somewhat sarcastic I mean
you know like
in that record has has a lot of that you
know which a lot of people I remember in
those days when that record came out a
lot of white supremists like took the
lyrics of that song like yeah these guys
are for us and it was like no it's
actually be very sarcastic a lot of the
lyrics you know but that doesn't matter
if you if you write a song where it's
like join the party they're like yes
please you can claim it's sarcastic but
if the average person doesn't interpret
it that way and it's a mixed message all
you're doing is telling people to be
white
nationalists well I think it I think
they're playing a character I think that
it's it's you
know I don't think
it's yeah it's like our song K had that
same kind of thing those like you know
it's they they play the part in order to
like to show the to be more clever about
it you know it's like it's it's and if
you don't get it then you're the idiot
kind of thing oh we did a song of that
genocide one of the lines is you're
marching you're marching to the beat of
just that's not what we are we watching
marching we literally are well I don't
think we are I don't think we are and I
hope that talking about it changes it
the weirdest I mean the weirdest thing
for me as a kid who who grew up punk
rock for as long as I can remember is
that it was all about sort of being
anti-government anti- big business
always questioning big Pharma always uh
being anti-war anti-industrial
military-industrial complex all of these
things were very and I Free Speech was a
very big one too and all of these things
were very they they also felt very left
too I like that that to me that's the
biggest the most bizarre thing of this
whole past few years is I'm the
literally the same person that I've
always been same beliefs same everything
else just the world around has become
this you're you're for free speech yeah
so so you're a
conservative no no no you are now but uh
yeah that's what say you can be standing
in the same place and the world sh
around you and now you're getting
pointed at literally doing the same I'm
saying the same thing I'm doing the same
thing I believe the same thing that I've
always believed as a punk rocker there
were songs that I can attribute like you
said with uh government flu with dead
Kennedy's was really about
Co like that that was a song that like
uh raised me you know I it's like the
all of that stuff is and I share those
same so the argument from the left is
that if you were a liberal in the N 1955
10 years later you're like I'm standing
in the same spot and all of a sudden
they're calling me rightwing for saying
we we shouldn't end segregation you like
what's going on dude it's like the NAACP
would while they were fighting for
Against Racism in fighting against
segregation and everything else they
were also fighting for the right of a
clansmen to be able to have their first
amendment right I mean the ACLU
S no no no no sorry no but uh the
argument from the left is that I'm a
high school dropout Tim so just I'm just
going to put that out there the the
argument from the left is that if you
were a traditional liberal in like 1955
10 years later after the passing of the
1964 Civil Rights Act you're like I
don't understand I've been standing in
the same spot but the world changed
around me and so their argument is yes
if you hold the same views you did 30
years ago you are a conservative because
they are the left and the Liberals and
you are the traditional right-wing
position reality though conservative is
an adjective it's not a noun so you are
conservative you are not a there is no
such thing as a there is adjective that
makes no sense it's like a green am I
really a green no green is an adjective
well now you're making stantic arguments
but people word liberal as a neutral
dude can be conservative sometimes and
be liberal sometimes and you can
conserve liberal principles like the
first amendment you obviously want to
conserve the First Amendment doesn't
make you a conservative like dude you
know like very wildly liberal like I
want to liberate I want to change the
laws too that makes me very liberal it's
just it's like you're wrong conservative
is a noun well that's what maybe the
internet tells you but
keep believe everything Google tell
don't put yourself in a box
unnecessarily do your P rock song again
hey I'm coming from the North and the
South but if you think back to like what
what what pun Rock was all about and
what it's always been all about it's
like at the moment right now I don't
know what the percentage is 70 80% or
more of all television advertising the
advertising that's taking place on on
YouTube it's all Pharma based right it's
like this is what we've been trained for
you know what I mean and we're funding I
don't know how many wars at the moment
like this is this is what this is what
we've trained for well I got I got I got
bandness for you guys if if you if
you're anti-war you have to vote for
Donald Trump
he's the antiwar candidate no he's the
first president in my lifetime that
didn't start a war he's the he he
created a timeline for the withdrawal
from Afghanistan I'm a Kennedy
man I think Kennedy would be good on War
as well yeah I think Kennedy would not
be he would be anti-war he'd be anti-
mandate so that's why a lot of people do
like Kennedy as well yeah I am but I
find that acceptable you know I mean
like
excellent ARF K Jr but is that but I've
refused to change my policy I don't care
how many wars there are on don't car I
still am going to be anti-war absolutely
yeah no I agree I'm never going to like
War I'm never going to support it I'm
never going to feel good about any wars
we're involved in and I think that we
should be sophisticated enough in the
modern world to just say enough's enough
and and figure out how to end it oh but
the machine needs to be fed I know you
know so so you got you got to throw
something into it have you got a nuke
something did you read Smedley Butler's
book no no but I I I've read excerpts as
the best I can say it's an easy read
yeah yeah he was that was the banker
plot right that was uh what was it
called he was the like the most
decorated Marine of all time and this is
a what was his book called it was the
the business of War it wasn't it wasn't
the banker what was that the the
business of War Smedley
Butler Wars a racket War racket anti-war
classic by America's most decorated uh
something or something the Wall Street
push the business plot gangsters of
capitalism yeah when uh they they these
guys went to Smedley Butler and said
they wanted to overthrow the US
government take over yeah but but anyway
but the whole book is about exactly you
know Wars a business war is a racket war
is we're sending people to die so that
other people can get richer and that's
hasn't changed a bit yep since good old
smedley's day yeah like after World War
II we were just talking about this on we
are change we kind of as a country had
an opportunity to decide how are we
going to unify this world are we going
to do it culturally are we going to do
it religiously are we going to do it
scientifically are we going to do it
through war and then Henry Kissinger God
Rest his soul just passed away at the
age of 100 was like we're going to do it
through war and we're going to do it
through limited War so we don't have to
bomb Moscow if West Virginia gets hit we
don't go right for the capital it's not
let's keep it limited but I think they
did us a great disservice the other
argument though is like if you just sit
tight and try and defend yourself and
just have strong borders that gives them
an opportunity to develop a sneak attack
and you've got to like be looking
outside and around for incoming
potential
threats I this like goes around and
around in my head like the
military-industrial complexes has 97
military bases all over Earth ultimate
like the Romans were doing the same
thing cuz like like the French thought
they they were safe from the Germans
before World War II they like we have
the the the magino line it cannot be
penetrated the Arden Forest to the north
cannot become we're okay we have a
strong defense and then the German had
invented some new technology with the
the Panzer tank and it just shredded all
the defensive capability they took
capital in three weeks they like went
South and then they went through the
forest through the forest unexpectedly
so like just sitting isolationism isn't
the way because then that gives them a
chance to build up their military for a
sneak attack but I don't know I don't
think that invading and conquering
countries is necessarily necessary in
order to you're just saying like maybe a
couple preemptive nukes on their capital
I don't know what to do cu the United
please tell me what he's saying really
having trouble following I think it's me
basically like if you don't Patrol your
borders beyond your borders like if you
just sit right behind the wall someone's
going to come over that wall so you've
got to go out there and like and that's
what our military indust this isn't
helping yeah Ian's basically saying he
wants limited Warfare like Kinser wanted
I I wonder if there's a better way to
establish Global dominance and and or at
least Global Order without without
warmongering oh economic Hitmen you know
like what if we sent uh intelligence uh
assets and special agents to go offer up
these these leaders of these other
countries bribes if they don't take the
bribes then we try to remove them from
power and then when that doesn't work we
can send in these uh uh these Sage these
coups and have them drug uh dragged
through the streets like U you know like
like like Gaddafi was you know may maybe
something like that Ian just trying to
buy them all off I I'm describing what
they literally do yeah it's disgusting
there's a do you guys know the tales of
the economic hit Hitman or whatever mm
I've yeah I forgot the guy's name Luke
Luke would know way more about this but
basically he said this what the US US uh
foreign policy is we first go to them
and say yeah you're going to do what we
want and we're going to make you rich
and they go I don't want to be rich I'm
going to fight for my people then they
say okay then we're going to do
everything we can to support your
opponents and put in a new leader good
luck if that doesn't work then they say
okay send in the troops conf that guy on
your show no no no that's John Perkins
is his name in the book's confessions of
an economic hit man yeah there you go I
read that book oh right so you know
about this stuff yes crazy dirty yeah
a republic evil crazy stuff unsurprising
we're at the point now we're like great
book yeah like the United States isn't
going to get invaded because they got
nukes Russia's not going to get invaded
China's okay they're not going to get
invaded India's not going to get invaded
so like we're kind of past the whole
conquer the Earth thing now maybe they
didn't expect that in the 50s they
thought like we have to but it's why
they're going for the One World
Government like economically the
economic forum is trying to build like a
a new order like a global order yeah
here's here's what I think you guys want
the truth yes the reason why all the UFO
stuff is coming out because what's
actually happened is is a Galactic
Federation of planets but the Earth
can't join the Galactic Federation
because there's no unified Earth
government to represent Earth to the
Galactic Federation and so they came and
the aliens were like look dude if you
want Earth in the Federation you need a
unified governing body to represent your
planet otherwise who are we bringing in
Russia or the United States or China
y'all going to blow each other up so you
get that sorted we'll be back and now
they're like quick quick we got to join
the alien Federation and that's why all
the news about aliens is coming out see
that proves it
wow I told Joe that in Rogan and he's
like I don't think there's a Galactic
Federation I'm like I'm joking like come
on man if I could pick I guess it sounds
a little plausible my perfect Way
Forward would be that our culture is so
badass that we establish such everybody
wants to learn English everybody wants
to dance like we dance and think like we
think that they start overthrowing their
totalitarian governments and create
statehood yeah the problem is though
half the country is like the parents
from Foot Loose we're trying to get
everybody to dance and they're saying no
dancing I think dancing is the answer
though you're on to something here yeah
Bill and Ted zon Adventure was prothetic
there you go yeah but you know what's
kind of sad is like Bill and Ted's
Excellent Adventure was amazing and then
Bill and Ted's Bogus Journey was just a
lot of fun yeah and then what was that
third thing they did that was just like
they took a dump on the floor oh I
didn't see the third one guys the 90s
was the last decade do you agree I feel
like it I feel yeah like the '90s so
once we got into like the 2000s but it's
nicer to hear a younger person say that
I would say yeah like my favorite my
favorite decade is probably the 80s just
because how insane it was with like the
leopard print hot pants yeah and the
mullets Y how much fun was that Tears
for Fears oh yeah and the and the busy
businessmen doing coke all the time but
Tears for Fears is just like one of the
one of the greatest act musical
performances of all I love Tears for
Fears and but I do love the '90s too I'm
a kid of the 90s but like we can look at
the ' 50s we recognize it we see the 60s
we recognize it 70s ' 80s '90s and then
the 2000s happened and it's kind of like
oh kind of for the first few years maybe
like long sleeve shirts underneath short
sleeve shirts or something and then it
just fizzled out and now it's just a
spattering of like especially filmwise I
would say I mean you know I my
14-year-old daughter loves 80s and 90s
movies she that's all she wants to see I
mean yeah goldhog day and and the
fashion too yeah oh yeah time kind of
first of all you should check out Roland
oral solo album Tom Cat screaming he's
the lead singer from Tears for Fears Tim
you're going to love that freaking Al
probably Tears for Fears is amazing but
when the internet gets started internet
video it kind of time ceased to exist
like time is first of all not a real
thing it's a human concept to explain
motion that wee we use it to coordinate
motion but basically things are just
spinning around in the universe
constantly moving all it is is moving
and so we built this thing called time
to like understand where things will be
when or where things are going to be but
I got I got to pause you there and and
just say we could do a whole show about
time is a thing it does exist so with
the static nature of internet video you
no longer wait till Thursday like you
don't have like next week on it's like
it's always there all the time so like
that's I think why this idea of like
decades are gone like it's all one space
now it feels like in a lot of way so if
you believe modern science and I can
totally get that a lot of people at this
point are like I don't even know man uh
time is a thing a construct no like
they've sent a bunch of uh uh spheres
into orbit that were like 41 hundreds of
an atom uh uh correct and then had them
drag through SpaceTime to prove
Einstein's theories that SpaceTime is a
tangable thing SpaceTime is a thing I'm
talking about and space and time are
right space time is a also cultural time
is is a different thing that we actually
had this conversation earlier talking
about you know there there was a
cultural change that that that was much
more rapid from the 50s 60s 7s man
things really changed yeah now things
don't really like decade by decade it's
you know musically and things like that
you're not seeing that drastic of a
change between what was happening in the
50s 60s I mean there was a massive
change just in in just a short amount of
time now now it almost like time has
slowed down
culturally and in terms of things
changing and things progressing that's
that's my theory on kids are going to
see bands now that you saw in the '90s
yeah yep like offspring are still
selling tickets oh dud there there was a
viral video of a woman wearing a Nirvana
shirt woman she was like 18 and she's
like I don't know what this is everybody
just has it they wear it and she's like
I I don't even know what it is and it's
like that's a band from the 90s my point
that making is though that and if if you
know Nirvana was still around people
would still be seeing Nirvana concerts
but I wasn't going to see the Big Bopper
in the
1980s exactly when you were exctly big
Boer was not headlining a festival in
1980 you know what I'm saying that's cuz
he got killed in a sorry bad example but
you know what my point is my point is is
50s AR 50s artists were not headlining
festivals in the 1980s where now the
artists that are headlining festivals
are from at least 40 years ago let me
ask you like so he fared us to the Big
Bopper if he was alive I worst example
sorry he hadn't gotten that little plan
when you guys were Bud Hol no not buddy
Harley when you guys were younger were
there like older dudes wearing jackets
that said like Harry Roy and his
orchestra or like Glenn Miller band no
or how about Harry James these were the
top bands of the 1930s you know my my my
guy over here is wearing misfitz jacket
we love the Misfits but like what is
that like 80s I love the'80s by the way
I mean so good right see what I was
saying you guys agree but I mean that's
that's 40 years ago Dude crazy 40 years
from like when I played with the Misfits
in 82 40 years from that it would be
like Back to the Future is a perfect
example Back to the Future like it's a
30e period and like oh my god look how
different the world was in 1955 versus
1985 like if if you do that you do that
from 30 years now it would not look that
much different you think the cultural
shifts that were happen drastic changes
from decade to decade was because the
mass media was like forcing us to see it
a certain way no I think the the lack of
interconnection actually pushes things
forward cuz then people are going oh
what's going on over there oh wait
what's going there's not so much
transparency I think that's just my own
Theory so like this homeostatic is
because we're so connected it's it's
slow it's not changing as fast now like
actors are getting AI versions of their
personalities getting created for future
movies James R Jones just said he
doesn't want to do Star Wars anymore but
they can have the rights to his they
already do have the rights to his voice
yeah so he's around forever like time
just stopped all of a sudden there's no
more did he sell the rights to his voice
or did he just say you could have it
well so
the challenge I think they're they're
definitely going to go and ask him I
think he did sell the rights yeah he did
the thing where you record all the
phonetic yeah permutations so it's but
we're also we're also at a point where
uh and 30 Rock predicted this one where
uh Jack donie played by Alec Baldwin
like oh yeah we have the rights to Jerry
Seinfeld's voice from Seinfeld so we can
just take all the recordings and then
Mash his lines and make a new show so
he's like he like that's technically
correct you could put him on in the
database and then run him through the AI
to make a new show using his voice yeah
I can I so we've done this with a voice
app like I can take any one of your
voices take Ian's voice I'm not going to
do it right now because I have to pull
the app yeah take it and then put it
through a filter so I can understand
what the is's been
dark a lot of other people but uh you
can take like a clip of Rogan for 10
seconds and then make Rogan say anything
you want I think I heard that clip I
think I heard they actually did that
yeah we did a we we've done a bunch for
fun we like Jordan Peterson
say stuff and you can just make anybody
say anything you want these days it's
crazy though because a lot these
Hollywood contracts will be like we own
your likeness in perpetuity across all
universes and every venue and it's like
Chris Hemsworth I don't know if he
signed that when he did th but to think
that Disney could do a deep fake of
Chris Hemsworth saying and doing
whatever they want him to do is like a
human rights violation if that guy
didn't give like he signed some contract
before deep fake technology
existed of all the human right
violations that are going to take place
going forward that that's going to be
the one I'm least concerned about I
think we should play some music yeah
yeah yeah I think if you guys want to
play some songs we'll we'll play some
songs I've run out of energy all right
well go to sleep I'm kidding let's get
it so get I'll pull up uh we we we'll
we'll we'll we'll inter intermix some
super chats while they're getting all
that stuff ready but I figure we'll do
the songs now we'll get the super chats
in and we'll go a little later than we
Norm I'll explain everything else to you
after that Dicky yeah while they're
getting the music stuff set up which it
probably take about a minute we'll grab
some Super Chat so smash that like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends and Carter
you're standing in front of the
camera sorry everyone up all right here
we go Zanna 520 says I regretfully have
to announce the passing of one of my
feline companions he was a trooper he
was abandoned survive abandoned survived
frigid Winters outside got shot and was
brought back from the brink it would
have to be cancer to finally take him
out rest in peace Toby Run free wow man
sorry to hear it Mr bcus is here you
know Mr bcus has got a he's got a a
neckerchief on right now because he
scratched his back up pretty bad and uh
but you know I don't know how much time
he has left but he made it a year he
made it a year oh listen to that look at
that you see they're getting ready that
sounds good I'm going to go to the
bathroom now that we're uh taking a
little interlude here we go it's going
to be
fun Ethan sacko says got to miss tonight
to see the shift I'll post how it is we
uh uh I I I want to be totally dishonest
you know we did buy tickets but with
Alex here we wanted them we we got we
filmed the commercial for Casper so and
then with sound check and production we
were just up here all day night we
weren't able to actually go see the
shift
yet check one two oh that's loud yeah
yeah is that too loud for you well why
am I in a
bucket I'm in a bucket dear
Eliza let's see yes which which which
camera is the uh I'll Swit it yeah just
give sorry give a we're playing
acoustically
I think that's worth mentioning it
sounds so good earlier thank you yeah it
was awesome but I don't want you know I
want people to buy the record our record
rocks it does and Pete doesn't sit on it
well that was funny cuz they played they
played one song it uh is it it is over
or it's over it is over it is over and
then I was like wait was that an
original and dick like you don't listen
to the
album I was like I got to be honest what
do I got to do what is it going to take
but the song was so good I was like wait
there there's no way that was like
that's too good you've done all right
for yourself come on I got I got to be
like okay then what I should say is
those other songs weren't good enough I
expect more from you guys what do you
think what song you guys got
[Music]
first this is my favorite but I think it
is over my my my new favorite Pete Pete
showed me the album early on and that
dead language I was like whoa that song
that slap
thank
you almost ready all
right how you feeling Friday night punk
rock show
acoustic Pete did this really awesome
thing where he's sitting on the kick
drum with his heel on the pedal you're
saving space
here okay well the the original music
setup we had was supposed to was like
we'll do an acoustic guitar and a singer
maybe but these guys were like we could
do it and I was like yes you can do it
yeah all right yep so this is the
defiant strip down
version you ready of a set first Trash
house sessions and uh yeah I'm ready
when you guys
are oh Waites
serges oh he trying to get the camera
real nice so yeah these these clips from
these sessions are going to go on the
trash house YouTube channel what's the
what's the channel is it trash House
Records on YouTube it is trash House
Records on YouTube Correct so all the
clips from all the songs will be up
there as well
correct and we got more coming I was
talking to Phil Phil said they're going
to come with all their remains later on
at some point when they're doing more
shows I'm like anytime buddy
cool dude I love the pet is just slammed
in the corner ladies and gentlemen the
defiant there we
[Music]
go
I go outside and leave this space I've
got the a still blast in my
face and I feel awkward and out of place
got everything I need right here
fingertips
literally and there's an out for
everything so I go back to reality is
clearly overrated by
there
why for in
love love is
[Applause]
f plus who's got that kind of time and
now we walk like zombies in the land of
the L reab
univ best be de language and the time
that you C thank the Lord for THS and
sleep by the well crawling from the
curve to the door I've had some deep
conversations with the living Flor
should have died in 27 like my heroes
before but I was too busy having fun and
I was too busy getting
done oh I fall in love I heard it's
blind a plus who's got that kind of time
and I can't dance and I don't drink wine
so what the hell is in it for
me
why fall in
love love is
F A Plus who's got that got time and now
we walk like zombies in the Land of the
Lost three fabricated
youzer the piece leg to the top that you
C I thank the Lord for
aable sleep in the well but craw from
the Cur to the door I've had some deep
conversation with the living room Flor I
should have died like my heres before
but I was too busy having fun and now
too busy getting
[Applause]
[Music]
done
and now we walk like zombies in the Land
of the Lost refabricated Universal R
cross be dead language and the time that
I thank the Lord for posable thumbs I
sleep at the whale crawling from the
curb to the door I've had some deep
conversations with the living room Flor
should have died at 27 like my heroes
before but I was too busy having fun and
I too busy getting
D and we're too busy we're too busy too
busy getting
done
Carter my headphones are not working
headphones not working all right it's
okay but that was fun did you it yeah I
mean you nailed it especially with the
monitors not working I'll take your word
for how where where you sounds great I'm
not using headphones so gold guys none
of you that song is called that language
how are your headphones they sound good
good let me know how those work out Che
don't lie to me P I'm not here to lie to
you check check all right this is the
way this sounds yeah okay all right you
pull that pull that reer back a little
bit they were in and out to be fair to
you they were in and out yeah we need
better uh connector cbles could buy you
a better pair I think that's right hey
Carter go to go to his actual uh his
actual Channel and just pull back some
of the EFX on his on the vocal chel
right there This song is called where
were you it's off of our album The
album's called if we're really being
honest send this out to the Tim cast his
listeners everybody tuned in
[Music]
yep
a you can't ask me how I am I know that
you give a damn I'll tell you I am
better than
nothing and I put
down ask me how I seem so sure I'm sure
that that would end the
discussion the r you mirror come my so
goodbye to every everyone in it and they
imitating life where were you all went
down when I needed someone you were
around why was it that you were the way
you found when I needed you tell me
where it was that
you and I I don't I don't know when I'm
coming home and here I I
look if this is my on the someone else
I'm tired
of the wind Shi D it looks right he
hoping that it might get
brighter the future driving right where
were you it all way down when I needed
someone you were around why was it that
you were nowhere to be found when I
needed you both tell me where it was
that you were at the time and where did
you go I for asking you but I'd like to
know where were
you and where did you go I'd like to
[Music]
know
where were you land it all down when I
be it someone you were in suround when
was it that you were the way to be found
when I beat you most tell me where it
was that you
were
all right all right nice that was nice
thank you yeah let's do these shoes and
it's over that's Liberty bro all
right okay hit that like button just
like you know put me on the spot all
right Joey let's go all
[Music]
right
in the year of Our Lord
220 I think that the month it was March
for Humanity SE we were asked you by
taking a break down the AR of
the the rug resist and the scrs insist
to engage would be too tall at T so do
not disturb and get kicked to the curb
neck no mention no B to
ask
oh
no where did Lady Liberty
go
oh yeah she pack up man I tell it out of
hand this silence was silent the
sidelines were full and the stands there
were standing
REM I spect that sport that you couldn't
cut short in a league where you left out
and some would look Inward and some
would D and others would just look
around keep your eyes on the shepher and
not on the sheep CH be blank you finally
found
oh
no lady
go yes she's out of here we don't know
where Ain it that you could care less
good day and God
blessed
I out of so many places now she can't be
found lost desperate cases just up and
where do you go when you're dagged and
you're B good day we say good day and
we'll see you
around locks St were locked and the
latches were latched on the cage and the
Cuffs in the
casket the workers up front were
dismissed or dispatched got a question
now it's time to ask it the H in the
highest wow how the mighty
Fallen I guess the whole mess was not in
the but do you hear the they
are
oh
no where did Lady Liberty
go
oh don't know where she went but we can
sure as hell tell you the reason why
good day a't
[Music]
good all right sick one yeah
sh what y'all got next for us for you oh
thank you d shoes
[Music]
right for a minute I thought my luck had
Chang I was little and in a dream s of
strength
I all the I was
away my eyes are white and I can see a
world gone black and all enough my heart
has not to Black I predict another sunny
day and I'm not ever
looking I get the
blues you couldn't walk a m in these
shes I'm not the kind that's going to
crumble and fall apart but when I look
around it really breaks my heart always
laughing on the
inside and I'm guessing that's a
start you
got
f but you couldn't walk a mile in the
show so good ring sounds around I would
break my fall we could pull it apart and
put it back together run before we C and
if everything nothing out nothing left
to you couldn't walk a mile in these
shows
[Music]
anything you have
a you couldn't walk a mile in the for I
thought my love can't change I was
living in a dream that seems so strange
I icted of the sunny day and I'm not
ever looking
back you had us
F thank you Father you were so
[Music]
cold but you couldn't walk a
m you couldn't walk a mile and you
couldn't walk a mile in the sh
[Music]
I that one up pretty badly nice
I'd like to apologize to my
band to Tim and your entire staff I'm
having a good time anybody if there's
anybody still listening I'm not wearing
headphones so I can yeah you got like
22,000 people all right then I won't
apologize to you
Joey our mix was so good earlier it's
still good all right okay yeah
noing I couldn't tell at all we're
louder
now getting I'm actually listening to
both what's going out and what's coming
from you guys so it sounds great yeah it
sounds good to hear a lot of shows they
don't have this kind of discussion no
it's true but i' like to think it makes
this one un talks to the sound guy the
first right I mean we were we were
planning for like come to Anaheim and do
our sound I'd like to talk to you during
the third song
sure we don't we don't have a yeah got a
little fire
[Music]
emotion where do we go
now that it is
[Music]
old we can't
stay if me that claring it's time we say
good night where do we go
now that it is
over we can't stay here in me that CL
and it's time to say good
night you don't want this to
end oh
you don't know when we'll be back this
way
again give them mys and let them no
there's no
regrets you know you don't want to let
it go just
yet just yet so where do we go
now that it is
over
you can't stay here if me that clear and
it's time we say good night where do we
go
now that it is
over we can't
stay it may that c it's time we say good
[Music]
night you know what we don't want to
live oh and we've got nothing up about
Slave oh when you give all you got to
give that's
when that's when you really start to
live my
friend my
friend where do we go now
that it is
over we can't stay here if that clear
and it's time we say good night where do
we go
now that it is
over we can't stay hell in that clear
and it's time we say good
night the beautiful sounds of the
[Music]
defiant will yet all we'll get through
we'll hold on and hold on to Memories
One bad we spr and
trust and we'll see it down the road my
friend it's just an ending not the end
fail we may both s away we
must and we
must where do we go
now that it is
[Music]
over we can't stay here me that clear
it's time we say good night
where do we go
now that it is
over we can't stay H it be that GL it's
time we say good night where do we go
now that it is
over we can't
stay every be back there it's time we
say good night
where do we go
now that it is
over we can't stay H if be back there
it's time we say good night where do we
go
now that it is
over we can't
stay GL it's time we say good night
where do we go where do we go that it is
over we can't
stay they me that where it's time we say
good night where do we go
now that it is
[Music]
over it's question we got to ask
ourselves now the casino what are we
going
that wasn't a
joke thank you hey on behalf of me and
the defiant thank you so much thanks for
everything what A really lovely time we
had that was awesome than thanks for
being our first uh first performance it
was very brave of
[Laughter]
you I know there is there anybody
listening still yeah 20,000 possibility
of that yeah we have a shitload of fire
emojis in the chat more
concerts
yeah you know you know to I think you
know just everybody understands guy just
said hard no I mean there you know you
get you know you
gets someone but song is really good
yeah that was my that was my favorite
it's over that language my favorite easy
like I know I know 90% of the words but
uh we we set this whole I know 90% of
the words too that's pretty good for you
you know but we we set this the other
ones it's
60% we set this up for for basically two
stools and like a guitar and maybe two
guitars and a singer and so for for the
first show we're like you know we'll
just maybe maybe people will be on the
coone and then uh you know the crew was
like no we want to do the full band and
and Carter's like we can pull it off and
so we I we did as best we could I guess
um we couldn't fit any more in here yeah
I think this I'm having a blast how you
guys doing having fun you got another
song yeah you want to do another one go
for R
absolutely I don't know Joey I try to
cancel one I met my love by the he
almost played The Archies I was getting
excited um do you want to try drugs uh
the answer to that is
yes who said yes over here we'll talk
later let's get exploratory my friend
was something we could play that would
sound
good question you got to ask
yourself
look at this dead space going on this is
not no pressure time to get back home
yeah we can finish out the Super Chat
here you know what look we got we got
the record right here let's look at what
we
got let's check check some of you guys
want to play the
impression can you play the one you open
with it y if you could play
it no no
a yeah how does that work one there's no
horns I don't know how you'd pull it off
why don't we just say good night okay
well it was your idea bro earlier today
he was like hey I've been in television
for a long time you only do four songs
well I guess we have to have you all
back for the I don't see any other way
of throwing us all out the
bus right everybody loves me yeah yes
RIP it oh yeah there you go all right
all right we got an oncore rushed right
over that one all right last one here we
go everybody good yep okay one two
[Music]
dagger about a knif I can kill you drams
and I can save you life I'm a red flag
in the F BL Street yeah going to have me
brag if you allow me to speak new's
going to kick the donkey took the punch
they took me out to dinner they said I
was at the lunch I'm been your dad I'm r
on your for everybody loves
me I'm the cut the F the bottom jaar I'm
down below the ra I'm going to way above
the law I'm full ofon s I'll put out
your fire and you burn your bridge I'm
the top shelf from the bottom rck I'm a
loose Canin and I'm a son of a gun I'm a
third rail I'm a cofin now but everybody
loves me loves me everybody loves me
loves
me everybody loves
[Music]
I'll build you up but a coule on a peg
I'm pushing all your buttons and I'm
pulling your legs so now press pause cuz
I'm a lost C but everybody loves me
loves me everybody loves me loves me
everybody loves me loves me everybody
loves me
yeahoo
yeah all right ladies and gentlemen the
Defiance see us play with the Aquabats
on the eth in Anheim
California fly out if you're not in the
area fly in it's the defiant
official.com yeah where can everyone
find you
guys where can they find us yeah other
than Anaheim at the casino and the
casino like online if they want to hear
these songs yo crer pull that EFX down
real fast oh yeah people your website
right now the defiant official.com is
that the best place for people to go we
have a YouTube channel as well the
YouTube channel let's find out is that
the defiant the defant official as well
yeah it's all what we're trying to bring
back is buying singles and albums
because they're more powerful than
streams so if we when when uh uh when we
put out our songs we asked everybody
just buy the 69 Cent version of the song
instead of just adding it to your
playlist most people as into music don't
actually care about the bands they don't
care about the culture they don't care
about winning they're like I'll turn on
my app and then press play on the radio
app or whatever and then in order to
actually get to a chart or whatever you
need millions of streams whereas you
only need like 10,000 purchases of a
song to actually get that high as well
so are you going to convince 10 million
people to listen to the song one time or
are you going to convince 10,000 people
to buy the song and have it in their in
their in their collection forever that
has a bigger cultural impact and it's
only 6 9 so buying the album buying the
song if everybody who cared about
winning the culture War bought their
music the only music that would be
succeeding are the bands that actually
ask their fans to buy music you you'd
knock out some of these big you know
mainstream pop artists really quickly
right to be fair that they still sell
like like the big guy like they'll sell
like 500,000 overnight of one of their
songs it's crazy right yeah but right on
gentlemen thank you for coming going to
have to mail all that out
that's come on man I'm a oneman show one
man
this sounds no I'll I'll take on that
either scenario sounds great to me right
on all right well I do want to grab just
a few more Super chats from everybody
before we we uh we we dip out just to uh
try try and squeeze those in and uh you
know read read some of the questions and
stuff that people have brought in so
I'll try and see if we can get a any any
of the good ones everybody loves me that
was a good way to I like that one that's
hot
yeah all right do we have any I want to
I want to try and you know try and do I
I'll try to make sure I'm uh we clarify
this next time we have acts though
because I think I think it would be
great if we had uh uh super chats for
the band questions and things like that
and I know we do have some but oh here
we go Stephen Frost says to me punk rock
music punk music is always the voice of
those who defy the government when they
cross the line Pete you are the true
Spirit of punk regardless of your
circumstance and you deserve all the
good that comes to you bro ah thank you
very much that's super sweet to hear the
machine the generator himself
Joshua French says mighty mighty Boston
got me through my first deployment when
I joined the Navy back in '96 Mass
respect damn thank you for your
service and thank you for yours thank
you and for yours Raymond g Stanley Jr
says this is one of my favorite episodes
mad chill Dicky is funny AF it's like a
culture War episode I can't wait for the
jam and then the jam happen so that was
from uh from earlier chat was going wild
during the music all fire emojis
everybody was super excited and and and
and you look you know I do tremendous uh
gratitude for you guys coming down being
our first ever attempt at like a live
show on stream so we're going to you
know we're going to we're going to we're
going to tweak it we're going to improve
the best we can so I really do
appreciate you guys coming thank you so
much yeah you get to the new place we we
can do a rock version the new place we
have like a pro company setting we have
like a big company coming in doing all
this crazy stuff whereas this studio is
basically we duct the whole thing
together it's so small no it's not a
small well people think it's small it is
small it is small what is small this
room yeah I think so what we're trying
to do well so for yes but this room is
16 by 35 yeah 16 by 35 so a lot of
people think it's like 8 by 10 or
something 16 by 35 we have a big table
the next room we're doing I think is
what it's 25 by I think 40 yeah about
that yeah 25 where's my pen and paper no
actually it's 25 it's 25 by 50 I mean
scratch long 25 by 50 yeah a lot bigger
bigger that larer it's a lot bigger
can't keep up with these numbers yeah
you got to do you got to do the math you
know you draw the
this room is 13 by 16 by 35 I think it's
a weird like yeah 16 the master bedroom
you think no this was called the the
sewing room the what room should live in
here once this was my bedroom before
it's too big for a sewing room but it's
too small for the defiant to rock out in
yeah I come from LA and that's so it's
funny that there's actually a room
called a sewing room where it's like you
barely have a bedroom yeah we have we
have we have a room what do we call that
I don't know it's the the room next door
is called the bonus room the child it's
the second living room the the living
room is called the great room because it
is a kitchen and a living room but it's
also massive yeah this is like a weird
building it really is yeah I wouldn't
this is not your normal kind of house
cuz it was I guess they duct taped a
bunch of different modular structures
together to make it I think this was the
kids that makes a lot of sense now
before we bought the place like that
makes sense it definitely makes Y when
you come here there's a window on the
top of the building and it took us like
a several months to be like wait where's
that window like what room is that and
then we went we went upstairs and
there's a wall there and there's no room
and then eventually we punched a hole in
the wall and there's a secret room like
how big is that room it's huge but it's
there's it's not it's un we play that
room next time you can't stand in there
it's completely unfinished and it's it's
it's like I'm so confused as to how
there's a window yeah and like how do we
fix the window if it breaks you can't
even go in there so there's a hole now
in the wall in this secret weird space
that was never finished it's just it's
it's crazy
building I've gotten lost in here before
yeah around just like wait there's still
more house like every everywhere I go
there more buildings five floors there a
godamn an enormous house pipe downstairs
yeah yeah six-footer there's a six foot
halfpipe in the basement of this
building all right everybody smash that
like button subscribe to the channel
share the show with your friends you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me personally at timcast the band
is defiant what was your you're
upsetting again the defiant official.com
buy the album albums are are big so what
we got to do we sell 10,000 albums more
about that off because everything you
said sounded good to me but I just like
ah I'm doing everything wrong sure I
mean yeah we uh let's let's let's get it
going thank you guys we made these
albums I don't think we have enough to
do those numbers though do we did we
make enough for that well he's talking
more in that Cas oh you're saying buy it
digitally not buy the album you can buy
vinyl too VL you guys sell the digital
album you should definitely buy the
album buy the album in any way there's
lots of ways to buy the album physical
album you guys out physical album
thought you were talking about actual
vinyl I thought that's what talking
about oh dude you guys have it on vinyl
oh I'm going buy you have a copy here so
so here's what we're doing for for the
new studio in the skate park portion
when we play music while we skate the
rule is you have to put on a full album
we bought an a 1990 sound system yeah
we're going to wire it to speakers and
the on the ceiling and everything and
then you put we're going to do a CD or a
vinyl you put it on you play it from
start to finish none of this randomized
radio nonsense thumbs up thumbs down no
no no no like real albums real music if
you want music that's what you got to do
those are the rules nice that's cool so
we'll grab your album for sure all right
guys thanks for out to everybody who
hung out this amazing Friday night for
our first first new jam session we have
more to come we're actually going to
start booking more musical guest so you
know we definitely want to reach out to
five times August because he was here
last time and we had this setup and we
didn't even think twice he was on pop
culture crisis and I was like bro we
should have had him come up and jam but
then also of course we have music and
we've got a new music video coming out
in 2 weeks oh yes and uh oh man I I I
can't say should I should I should I
should I mention a little bit about what
we have going on I think you can mention
a little bit uh don't we shouldn't
promote it just yet cuz only today I've
got all the numbers synced up and
everything but it's going to be coming
out I just want to mention um we fully
expect Michael noes and Jeremy boring to
be in the video so uh that's all I want
to say for now but it it's going to be
so much fun so anyway uh yeah if uh if
Ian wanted to Carter Ian you want to
shout shout shout out anything before we
wrap up I just want to say thanks for
coming out and being the first band guys
like I'm I'm so happy with how it went
tonight uh it sounded great and just so
everyone else knows that you you can
hear all this that we had tonight will
be uploaded to uh trash House Records
YouTube um and yeah right on that's it
yeah man be good to yourself cuz that's
where it all begins and then you be good
to your community good to meet you guys
that was rockar that was hot
let's do this again looking forward to
it right thank you thank Serge you want
to say anything before we sign off uh
yeah my camera got all screwed up there
so that's the best we got for the moment
but yeah peace thanks guys for coming
through that was fun really appreciate
it let's get all right everybody yo it's
going to be it's going to be a real
really wild next couple of weeks we're
going to be at amfest on stage with
Tucker Carlson and Charlie Kirk I hope
you guys are watching or if you're there
we're going to have a whole lot of fun
we've got more music coming up we're off
for the week of Christmas but thank you
for joining this 1st of December and
we'll see you all
Monday